all right we're beginning our travel on
to Iceland the time is currently 112
p.m. channel yours was Oliva one we're
heading to the airport
and then we we go we go to Iceland times
115 we are now out the door this outfit
is awful this have got new boots does
boots doe can't look at you you can't
come I'm so ready my allergist they're
better we know allergens in Iceland
because I'm I'm you melting get in the
minivan immediately arrive to the
airport we're about to park and get in
there I've also now changed my time to
24-hour time so it is 14:05 actually
already gone
real early
we just eat lunch something brought to
the gate and uploading my video
getting these copies of the tweets a
minute oh no our what oh but you cook
that sledding sledding mmm oh yeah so
1521 chronicling
- major toy it as a reminder ladies and
gentlemen smoking is for on that design
please observe just lady constant
not
it's too late
how many people
security
we've got seven hours before our flight
here we go one person
18:31 back on a shuttle going to another
terminal because they have more stuff
there
18:48 try to push up a shuttle there's
nothing here
terminal e oh my god I can't believe
19:11 got the bag tag that I lost now
it's back to terminal eva we were maybe
two hours ago
no like our minutes no we were to eat a
long time ago another shuttle same day
same hour
19:25 I'm about to change my clock back
to 24 hour times I keep getting confused
we're about to have actual dinner
I'm tired we walked a long way long time
long time walking tell them wine I don't
want to talk 1929 oh my god Toby
Cooper's coming off thoughts of ordering
sangria hoping crosses a pitcher what
are our options
I don't know we'll get back to you 19:35
contacts coming out we figured out why
don't take 4 0 15 hours you're gonna see
self-destruction does your bucket
abstain 3 again you do you remember when
you said it's give me 27 do the math
wrong let's rise alright have you shot
your joy yes we do
sangria sangria yes Brad oh oh I like
white like really pick it little weak
yeah would you want to thank you for
this chicken 1938 also our area
that's almost 1939 the state is ground
control to you too
is there a hashtag for this event 1939
yeah it's project money she's got my
hero 1942 and sangria is here yay 2017
glasses on sangria half go on
oops 20-something hundred time washed
Cape has blanket
about to eat a candy bar my mom packed
in my bag for me thank you mommy
I'm tired and I want to be in Iceland
now I want to go now
okay 23:26 we're finally about to board
and I need to find a bottle of water
it's been such a long day I'm exhausted
but that's the nature of traveling
especially international travel 23:45
will board him here we go hey Jenna
what'd you do hey hey you're my sister
get it
the perfect
if there's somebody sitting here do sit
there the flavors tended movie said
awkward they're like those would look
steady like this
we're sitting right here I like room
when did you go down here I mean you're
probably awesome really fast you think I
cannot believe what I just saw my two
eyes the time is now zero hundred
dollars you in Stein Oh thinking about
it got a cup of sugar
our time is 9:30 zonda we're getting off
the plane yeah that means I need mix in
which can coffee have them
you've got coffees we're picking up our
bags and let me continue onto the
journey bags we got all our bags Jen
time update 6 no three no oh ah where am
I
9 10 1003 1003 oh my god our bag behind
you copy
all right off the hotel I'm very excited
for a shower shower is a great idea 1017
on the shuttle to hotel eating yogurt
get that my face 11:07 we're at the
hotel but it's the wrong one
so our child left us so we have to try
to somehow get it to come back we get oh
he's he's pretty Jules bolts official I
just picked up a big map Jen I got a big
wrapping
they're big madam harina two o'clock
it's too close to my face you cannot see
it shuttle I think it'd be better I'm
sure be happy Jennifer we're here most
elevator ever no really
oh no oh shoot we're gonna go back down
oh really
get back in I don't want to go back down
if it's problem oh yeah no this isn't
right so world the wrong place
yeah she told she applies did you guys
have his side really can you read the
numbers yeah why didn't you say go the
other side oh my gosh I can't wait do I
don't lay on this I'm dirty complain
look the time is 11:30 eight eleven
thirty eight Jen do the math how long it
take us to get here I don't even know
where I am right now I'll get back to
you on the math please do okay first and
foremost shower nap then worry about
that later
all those things let's do it okay 12:05
this will be my last update of this vlog
I'm gonna take a quick little nap this
has been a really really long travel day
but I'm looking forward to seeing what
you guys vote for us to do um I'm hoping
we get to do all of the things if time
permits but I know they also say right
now is I'm too tired so I love you guys
also be sure to stay tuned on my Twitter
and my facebook & Instagram and YouTube
and all the places because I made you a
meet-up on Sunday possibly it's not 100%
so don't get too excited but hopefully
it'll all work out goodnight